[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link joining us at the round table
of dim lighting this week is mythical
crew member Lizzie we are going to be
discussing the topic when is it okay to
lie is it okay to lie ever is it ever
okay to okay to lie fibbin thank you for
all of you mythical beasts who are
contributing to the conversation via
your questions and comments it's a it's
a big conversation that we're excited to
have it's a thicket that we jump into
but first we want to do a little
catching up with you guys shoot the
breeze a little bit shoot a little too
that ear biscuit breeze you know how
you're baking up a biscuit and sometimes
it just wafts through the house do
biscuits happen at your house huh they
happen in my house about every Saturday
my brother you eat biscuits every
Saturday I would say average one point
five Saturdays every hour what month per
- well you could probably there's
another way that would be three out of
four or be another way to say that so
it's like I don't know that every
Saturdays had a foot of a month yeah
biscuits yeah yeah 1.5 out of - no -
well I'd already said 1.5 so I reduced
the fraction in difference any fractions
wasn't a class but I know when a biscuit
smells good and that's what we're doing
I love biscuits but no we don't we might
tend to not having biscuits at the house
because I don't think they're good for
you they're good for your soul well good
for your heart the ones out of a can are
really good for you yeah the pillsbury
ones that pop out when you twist the can
well I'm not going never twisted the
camp I'm not gonna mention the brand but
yeah twist that can and they pop out
sometimes they pop out and I said well
that was a cinnamon roll but you don't
gonna put eggs in it usually it says it
usually indicates it on the package I
know you don't cook a lot but typically
it says it all the packaged word sensor
I know that you use the spoon to pop it
Oh a cinnamon roll came out milestone
our boys lock in Lincoln
just hit a milestone which I mean we his
father said a milestone they played
there the final game of their season of
basketball together first season a
basketball recreation league basketball
together exciting season especially
exciting game because what happened well
spoiler alert they lost the game but
Locke had 37 points yeah which is pretty
amazing
he was pulling up the slack for a reason
that I'll get into I think it was first
quarter it was like the first few
minutes of the game right like I would
say there was probably six possessions
when this happened that's in my memory I
was Hurley I know you don't understand
fractions but there were halves not
quarters the NBA our kids are not in the
NBA just in case you didn't know that
they're they're just playing recreation
basketball that is painful they don't
even true they don't even stop the clock
when things they didn't even stop the
clock when what you're about to describe
when did when did when did it happen
because it happened about how many I did
my mind it was six possessions of the
game yeah well I mean I'm up filing a
police report because I'm just I'm just
making the point the very early believed
there was any criminal activity what are
you trying to say no I'm just saying
very early and are you taking this not a
lot of I'm reporting this recorded this
about a wire only no it's being recorded
for Quality Assurance purposes only it's
not being distributed in any way what if
you haven't held whatever I'll hold it
against you what if you had on a wire
right now like what if that would be
that would be redundant what if we were
you were like I was being investigated
and they had gotten to you in the way
that they were doing it was putting a
wire on you wow we made a podcast
nightly public I would tell the cops
hey guys you don't need to save your
batteries at this point we have a
microphone you can do don't don't
don't burn the wire during the podcast
because it's being recorded in another -
is that cynical you do know the FBI burn
the wire you know the term burned the
wire all right you got me I'm I'm Wyatt
I'm currently being patted down in the
chest by referee
we're only listening what are you what
are you try think you gotta find out I'm
so very I tell you everything you know
why Yeah right very early in the the
basketball match this is developing so
fast
Lincoln's under the basket dribbling and
I noticed there was one guy who's huge
like I mean Locke is hit a growth spurt
he's a lot taller than Lincoln who's a
little bit over a year younger than him
but this guy was at least a year older
than lot and he's anti still taller than
Locke
he's your size this guy weighs as much
as you do so Lincoln like pump-faked
under photo you you're cutting way too
early to this you just said Lincoln was
under the basket dribbling no no no no
that is not what happened my friend this
was a fast break you blocked all this
out it's a fast break yeah Lincoln was
mmm some people will call it
cherry-picking that's when you didn't
quite get back on defense and you're
under your own basket in a position to
score no he wasn't he was at midcourt he
was halfway back to play he was halfway
back and then they stole the ball lock
gets the ball locks dribbling up the
court and Lincoln's running SAS break he
sees Lincoln Lincoln his wide open under
the basket rocket pass right to Lincoln
that's where now you can pick up where
you work cuz and this huge giant of a
man almost not I mean I don't he's not a
boy he was so much bigger than anyone
else he's on the line between a man and
a thought he could have been a coach
it's like why is it coach playing yeah
player coach Lincoln pump fakes the guy
goes for a hook line and sinker jumps in
the air then Lincoln goes up the second
time a little too early and and meets
nothing but this guy falling down on him
they they crumpled to the ground and the
guy rolls off of him and immediately
Lincoln rolls over and he's like his
hand was like shake shaking a little bit
and I was like I mean Kristy has
suffered a concussion a year ago and
we're very paranoid about anyone hit in
their head because of all that she's
bent that's why wears a football helmet
her in the basketball
he's the only he's the only one doing
her she was like did he hit his head and
I was like I think he broke his arm bad
like that's what I was thinking about it
and say anything I thought his forearm
was like snapped underneath this kid but
then he rolls over and he's like he's
shaking a little bit and then I was like
I thinking I'm not going over there
because you don't a a parent doesn't
immediately you should as a parent you
should really run over you don't want to
be that parent of wrath and the coaches
of all teams a whole system ran over
right so the parents are supposed to
keep their distance and say you know
what let's not let's not incite panic
here in in the child and let's just let
him deal with it so I'm sitting on the
bleachers with Christine like she's kind
of panicking I'm like he didn't hit his
head I think it's his arm and it's like
it was very surreal this has never
happened to me before
having a child who seems to be injured
and then after a while he didn't get up
and then Chris he's like I think you
need to go over there I don't know if if
would you have gone over there earlier
than I did did I do something wrong by
waiting no I always minimize the
situation and I yeah I minimizing I was
minimizing that situation I was like
okay I always err on the side of and
when I went you don't wait up even when
I went up I couldn't see any bones
sticking out that's really what I was
afraid of this well part of why I ever
would
you heard of it their friend herself I
don't wanna see any bones sticking out
of me no that's not why maybe
subconsciously but consciously I wanted
to respect the process I go over there
there's no signs of anything really bad
he's all he says his wrist hurts it's
like okay it's it's may be broken but
then they could move it they got him to
move it and make a fist I'm like all
right he can move all his fingers and
move his wrist it's just sprained really
badly and he goes and sits on the bench
and then we watched some more of the
game while the coaches talked to him and
they iced it I go over there and the
coach is like I I think he's pretty
shaken up you might need to take him
home and put some ice on it and you
might need to see a professional yeah
and by that I took him to mean an NBA
player correct yeah you need to go guess
I was like do you know any person
yes he'll be inspired hey that's my cool
B I love their help for them to help ya
so we take it the next morning we took
him to the doctor and lo and behold he
broken his wrist in two places there's a
lot of bones in there and Lincoln said
it wasn't from his his wrist hitting the
ground or his arm jamming against the
ground it was the guy hyperextending his
hand when he landed on his hand at
hyper-extended his hand backwards like
if you were to take your fingers and
pull them back to touch the top of your
forearm and somehow that broke up some
stuff yeah like but the edge I don't
know but no but no ligaments no
ligaments it was just he's in a cast now
he's starting
he's starting school with a cast on his
wrist I know Christi was talking about
she was you know she was like oh you
know he started yeah this is all our
kids are going from basically being
homeschooled and doing some some like
charter school to school and public
school they're all little little
apprehensive about this some more than
others but I know that Christi was like
all me now he's he's gonna be the kid
with you the cast but I'm like that's
great yeah but I was so like yeah he's
gonna be the kid with the cast he's guy
he's the kid who's got something to talk
about you got it you got a take I mean
you you got a Dustin opportunity he's
got something he's got the people kids
do people still sign cast is that a
thing Lincoln I looked at his cast he
comes home he's got a bright lime green
cast and there's he's already had people
signing it and I look and write where
his watch would be in big bold letters
it said don't give up with a thumbs up
and I'm like looking at the cast on my
oh that's cool you got a lot of people
to sign your cast who wrote that
don't give up thumbs up and he was like
me and I almost said it's got a great
attitude bit my tongue I wasn't truthful
as will get you so filtered this
conversation through the one we have
with Lizzie if I should have said
something but what I was thinking was
well you don't write on your own cast
son but I couldn't fault him because he
drew a thumbs up and everything yeah
don't
what time is it time to not give up and
you know what so far he hasn't given up
well it's because the cast is still on
yeah I take it giving up means don't
give up on making up a great story every
time someone at my new school asked me
what happened
writing is what it really means you know
what now the thing that you really gotta
worry about in these situations when you
when you've got something that then
leads to a story is you got to have the
details down so you're a good
storyteller
I know he may have inherited that but I
don't know if you've given him the tools
yet because you got he's got to use
terms like sick head fake
you know you he's got it no I don't even
think it's related to basketball oh I
think it's related to like an expedition
in the Amazon okay well that's in direct
contradiction to everything that we're
about to talk about in this podcast and
whether or not it's okay to lie okay you
can give him the false story that you
can give to some people but I'm saying
this insatiable eyes slightly
exaggerated sick head fake story that
will get him a lot of street cred that's
all I'm saying this is an opportunity he
needs to take advantage of it you need
to give him the tools the vocab tools
and then he can write that on his cast
you can write the story Batum well don't
give up on this podcast as we take a
moment to show some love to our sponsors
that's right and we want to let you know
about the all-new mythical store that's
right rattling dot-com slash store is
now mythical dot store that's so it's a
mythical dot store I can do that now you
can read new stores with brand new good
mythical logo merch including this
freaking coffee mug that debuted on The
Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon he we got
we asked him to make a big deal out of
our new coffee mugs because we told him
look at that you can't have a good show
without a good mug you can have a good
mug without a good show people do that
all the time
look at that logo link look at how that
shows up on a shirt look and not just
that shirt there's other shirts but
that's what I'm holding up look at how
this logo shows up on a hoodie
we got a gray hoodie with the all wrong
are never around and look at that it's
also BAM on the back double logo you got
logo on the front logo on the back we
also have good mythical summer
collection merch so go over there and
get that the summer the summer days are
waning guys but technically it is summer
so get your good mythical summer merch
and your good mythical summer that's a
great way to identify fellow mythical
beasts out on the lake
mythical dot store and now onto the
biscuit so here we are with Lizzie thank
you for joining us
oh you're welcome anytime is that a lie
are you already lying probably anytime
we can ask you to just show up on your
biscuits and you'll do it actually yeah
I like doing this did you feel like you
had a choice I could have said no I
wanted to be here but when it's when an
answer or retort is a little awkward or
self-incriminating then you're you you
can believe that it's not a lie so right
off the bat that's that's what I'm
offering as disarming to this
conversation it's like well you don't
have anything to gain by saying what you
just said you have a lot to lose
Sharon of fact you're fired by so it
seems like what you're saying is that
it's all about positioning and just you
know leveraging for your own benefit
what you know I'm saying if you assume
that people are lying then you can have
a good good reason to believe that
they're not and that you're wrong if
what they said doesn't benefit them in
any way that's all I'm really saying
you're saying that it's also ultimately
a manipulation
yeah that's pretty accurate but I mean
there's the other thing of you know if
somebody says I'm not lying and then
follows it up with something else
they're like almost certainly lying
that's that's a clue you can usually
look so I'm not a racist
right so they are okay right this list
we're not talking about that that'll be
another podcast
if I were a racist no just maybe racism
in general now okay that's better okay
but I am very excited about this
conversation because what we're trying
to do and I think this is the first of
its type on ear biscuits is we're trying
to have a conversation in the context of
community ccc like Central Carolina
Community College oh I love that place
it was in between Buies Creek and
Lillington we would drive powerfully
still is there I didn't attend it but
lots of fine people did lots of great
degrees feel like I learned a lot just
going past that community to your school
I'm sure they're doing great now listen
the thing that excites me is that we're
gonna have a conversation about is it
ever okay to lie but we're not just
gonna have a conversation the three of
us not just the two of us it's not just
the three of us it is the wider
community of mythical beasts so I don't
know this is definitely an experimental
thing and it's not like Oh going through
fan questions is some monumental
innovative thing and we're the only
people to ever do it but I think that
what we've learned over the years in
making content for the mythical beast is
that this isn't just this we've talked
about this million times this is not a
one-way relationship where we create
entertainment and they just consume it
this is a there's a relationship and
there's a back-and-forth and a lot of
that conversation may kind of pivot
around that the content that we put out
there but through the devices of social
media and I guess that's the way that we
talk to the most people sometimes in
person this is an ongoing conversation
usually about the things we're creating
but because we talk about and have the
opportunity to talk about a lot of
different things on your biscuits we're
like what if we talked about things that
people actually had it has nothing at
all to do with entertainment it's just
stuff that people think about in their
lives in their everyday experience and
can we as a community kind of arrive at
something I'm not saying at the end of
this podcast that we're gonna know that
what the mythical beast heard rules are
about lying very good selection we will
have taken a step towards maybe helping
all of us understand a little bit better
about this particular concept well and
I'm I just want to hear funny stories
about
people who glide yeah that's what that's
what I'm here for the whole thing was
dishonest the whole intro is dishonest
yes caught it out your liar rat so
Lizzie we asked you to to cull some some
input from mythical beasts about lying
yeah I got some very interesting
responses little white lies mm-hmm big
hairy lies all types of stuff but I
think before you present what you found
we I want to hear that the three of us
are willing to talk about when we've
lied because I mean we joked about it
some but we've all lied in one form or
another oh yeah and it and we've got it
we've got a we've got to be a part of
this we're not just gonna put it on the
the tweets and facebook comments that
you're gonna read right yes I would I
would go as far as to say that I'm not
just a liar I actually have a
disposition towards dishonesty in many
different interactions
most of them inconsequential as most
people would consider them what I mean
is that my problem with honesty is not a
I have like a deep moral flaw and I
cheat on my taxes and I and and I'm
doing these things that most people were
considered like immoral it's more I have
a tendency to just kind of well socially
flatter people an example laughing is
something that's not funny
that's dishonest I do it all the time
with you especially not with me man no
I'm not talking you know you in between
the two of us I you know laugh at all
I'm no I was joking I'm much worse about
this but if me and you you know you
weren't joking about laughing at other
people's jokes though right no no I'm
saying that between you and me you don't
laugh no you you only you only laugh
honestly no no no I'm saying if me and
you are hanging out with someone mm-hmm
especially someone we don't really know
that well and they say a joke that's bad
or they say something like I'm much more
likely to laugh at laugh for them to
make them feel and you're much more
likely to be honest and if there wasn't
funny to not laugh that's like I feel
like personally that's a flaw but if I
say the joke
it's always funny you won't rattling
that's always funny if it wasn't will it
laugh because we have a we've got a
comedy bit going here I can't you know
I'm saying it's like I'm doing I'm I'm
not laughing at you for community fest
that's a professional relationship no
I'm worried that you were like that's
terrible then you laughed at it yeah
definitely right if you do it in that
order doesn't work I don't if you say
that was terrible hahaha then you kind
of know that the laugh is disingenuous
oh no I don't know I'm just saying I
have the disposition socially to be
dishonest most people wouldn't think
that it was common courtesy but and I
don't want to get into this now because
I I'm actually thinking but I've been
thinking about this let's just take that
as an example that's me in a nutshell
with my know where my dishonesty I'm
still suffering sorry my throat so I I'm
prepared to jump in and talk about when
I've lied but I and I hope you are as
well
I am I well cuz when you guys asked me
to do this podcast and you said are you
comfortable sharing a story about when
you've lied I was like sure and then I
started thinking back vacuum right
before you thought of no I don't mind
I started thinking it through and I was
like I think I had a similar epiphany to
you which is that I realized I think I
just accidentally lie a lot or or lied
to keep the status quo or you know not
not be quote-unquote rude about
something but it was more that when I
was thinking back on any life
experiences where I lied I couldn't find
a single one where I had lied and it had
turned out well so even if it was
something little like the story that I
can share today was not a big or serious
thing but it immediately turned around
and and bit me in the butt almost
literally which you'll find out about oh
yeah yeah so where do you want to go do
you do you want do we want to hear from
a mythical beast
sure what what how about before we get
into the questions if we just just I if
we could just state our general opinion
yes or no okay is it ever okay to lie
okay just just just first starters just
throw that out
I'll I'll start by saying that I think
if you are lying to protect the safety
of your I don't know don't reason it out
just give me a yes or yes yes and I can
explain what you're just asking for a
yes or no answer yeah for no rig no
reasoning okay
give you again what's your my reasoning
is yes if it's if it's to protect
yourself or someone else then yes like
there's there's the thing of if there's
a murderer at the door and the murderer
is asking you about the location of
their next victim are you gonna be
honest and say where they are are you
gonna lie okay you would like well I
would like
well I wouldn't even respond because my
lie would be that I'm not there well
it's not you it's someone else is
getting murdered you can't just no
excuse me I'm a murderer I want to see
if your next-door neighbor's there it's
like well it's like someone shot also
not here all of a sudden I'm lying I'm
lying to protect my tail sure caught you
yeah if they barged in they broke in and
you're there in the living room Wells
Rhett hiding under the couch yeah cuz
I'm trying to kill him right yes or no
is it okay to lie about that yes that
seems like an easy question yeah not
necessarily though people would disagree
with you on that
mmm so I I can't think of many examples
but I the example is gonna think of a my
own life I feel like well no harm was
done or but was there or could a lot
could good have been done if I would
have told the truth like I'll give an
example because I just don't I can't
give them a simple answer
because I would just say no yeah I would
say yes there has to be occasions where
it's okay to lie because that's a tough
stance to say no you can never lie yeah
last night I was at the Olive Garden
with my family how did that happen we
were in a certain weariness yeah I'm not
gonna dog Olive Garden I have not been
to an Olive Garden when you're literally
over 10 years I've not been to an Olive
Garden and I did not bring up the Olive
Garden but
turns out we were in a neighborhood and
the kids knew there was one and we're
like let it live I'm watching
commercials that's no they saw the sign
they knew this area and I was like let's
grab something to eat and all three of
them said Olive Garden and because they
had like talked amongst themselves it
there was an Olive Garden there and I'm
like Olive Garden I haven't eaten there
in over 10 years
but the breadsticks I remember the
breadsticks I'm Way back my mom and I
used to go a lot when when I was in
Middle School which was more than 10
years ago I've been after but the thing
to put me over the edge is my three kids
have never agreed on a place to go okay
so we went to Olive Garden no this is
partners his story except we're at an
Olive Garden so I'm sorry for dragging
this out and we're sitting down there
and the breadsticks come that was one
thing I was looking forward to until the
next thing which will be like the salad
and then the next thing which we've been
like the lasagna or that trio they got a
trio of three things we can get a
lasagna and two other things not a smile
I remember usually I remember you maybe
one day and then I'll change how is it I
was pretty excited once I got here and a
little embarrassed and they've got the
breadsticks
and I was like to the whole family I was
like dang these breadsticks are hard as
a rock these are not as good as I
remember them being and then the
waitress says how is everything and I
realized she was right there right there
no like literally her head she could
have like stuck her tongue out licked me
so she probably heard she didn't she's
been trained she's a waitress at all she
hears breadsticks and she just turns
right off so literally was that close I
was in time I was like these breadsticks
are hard as a rock this is not I
remember them being great how is
everything that was the timing and of
course you said great yeah everything's
great the lie that I hope everybody
along with me can agree that they that
they lie when put in that situation
sometimes I say it's bad and I ask for a
new thing yes this year the reason why
you lie is because
the awkwardness associated with that
type of exchange and then like this the
self questioning and every it's just a
derailment of your whole evening then of
trying to it's not worth it getting
something good to eat
in it's not worth getting hot and soft
breadsticks right so just to be honest
because of all the social organist the
reason why I lied was so that it
wouldn't feel awkward yeah I completely
understand it completely relate and I'm
worse than you are and being dishonest
in those situations yeah here's what
I'll say I don't want to get into
because I have a theory about this it's
a theory in development and we can I
don't want to get into it now because I
want to get into some questions but you
both stated what I think are the prevail
is this sort of the prevailing cultural
perspective on dishonesty which is of
course there are times when you should
be dishonest when somebody's life is in
danger your personal safety is at stake
and then sort of the second layer is of
course dishonesty is okay when you're
avoiding some sort of cultural hurt well
it's not worth the time know that I
wouldn't call it cos I think there's two
different things being presented one is
those are two I think there's a to
totally separate thing to sever one is
it's okay to it's okay to lie if it
protects someone or yourself or no but
what I'm saying is all those things are
every almost everyone agrees with those
two things right and the other one is
what it's okay to lie as long as it
doesn't hurt anybody
now I think we can all saving it yet I
think but if you state it that way I
don't I don't know I might be on shaky
ground and that second one is the one
that I'm beginning to think differently
about but let's get into some questions
or comments or whatever they are stories
sure so the first one that stood out to
me is from Elizabeth huh Reich may be
right I don't know you got a great name
it's anytime someone asks isn't my
newborn beautiful do that do they do
that yeah no they're never it's been a
long time since I've had a new boy
almost seven years so I don't remember
ever ever asking someone it isn't a
common question but it is a common
situation they're so squishy this
this was a way of cutting to the very
specific probably not very realistic
question scenario or they ask you but
what the typical scenario is here's the
bay here's the baby you're so now you
say something nice you're supposed to
say something nice doesn't matter if
it's true but there are ugly babies we
can all acknowledge that and let me tell
you just first of all the whole
situation with little babies yeah and me
I'm I'm not cut my hands are too big I'm
to tie off the ground chair I'm worried
about dropping them I was like a good
commanding my own children if you're
gonna watching a little pain you're
holding babies you want your hand to be
big I do not deal with you don't want to
have little hands in a tall body I'm
gonna don't run the whole debate I don't
know it would just feel like they could
slip through two of my fingers
I have clammy hands I'm afraid is just
gonna slide out that girl she on her or
something good there slick it's actually
right when they come out I don't do well
with births or deaths somebody dies I
don't know how to comfort you I love
death somebody somebody is born I don't
know how to compliment
but the situation at hand this is this
is great cuz this is what yeah this
isn't what we just talked about with the
waitress which is somebody you don't
know listen this is somebody don't you
know you do know and you're going to
tell them that their baby is beautiful
it's typically the worst yeah that's
right or so cute
yeah I mean I was a really hideous baby
and I'm sure people said I was adorable
and I looked like Winston Churchill in a
bow I know you have to find a way to say
something that is kind I think the Holy
Grail is something that's kind and
truthful so you pick the one good thing
about the baby that's gonna be something
like your this fear or just like more
nebulous like yes little Jared is such a
beautiful concept Hawaii looks smart
like a new being coming into the world
is a beautiful thing isn't it what you
make it like there's lots of tactful
ways around it it's a tactful way just
say it's beautiful like what is the
point of being like why well he's got
your nose there's a needle thread here
he's got your nose your nose happens to
be horribly ugly but no but you don't
have to say made that part
Jared no here it's daddy knows which
raises a different issue is withholding
the full truth is that lying I don't I
don't believe so
omission right no if you say the baby is
oh but if you say the baby's beautiful
and the baby's not and you don't think
the baby's beautiful well that's a lie
yeah well I didn't want to get into this
yet because part of my working theory
you keep not wanting to get into things
my part of my work we here for my part
of my working theory is that we would
all be better off if we made a cultural
agreement that the truth was so
important that it was okay to speak it
at any time in any situation
so yeah if I want to hold myself to that
then I would say that if Jared's baby is
ugly I don't know how jared is in this
situation
you mentioned Jared Jared wasn't the
favorite was now Jared senior is the
Jared Junior and Jared see yeah I think
if I go if I go with this theory that
I'm saying that I believe the world
would ultimately be a better place if
you tell Jared his baby is ugly it's
just it's he if he has signed the
cultural contract that but what does
what you get when you but what is ugly
first of all I mean we're bringing a lot
of different things we say Jared I don't
personally find your baby appealing I
find your baby repulsive if you were to
say that that would that would be that
would be true but that doesn't mean it's
even tolerable but in the contract they
in the context of him but something we
get true and bad something could be
false and good but in the context of
date today's culture that would ruin it
would do a lot of things he would ruin
your relationship with Jared and Jared
jr. you would never have a relationship
with them again because you want it
though it's an ugly baby right true but
yeah sometimes think girl to be
beautiful just kidding I'm kidding
yeah yeah where where there's a whole
lot of other things pent up this
conversation about our perception of
beauty which we're just using this as an
example there is no baby Jared that's
ugly or pretty okay this is just an
example but you know babies yes that's
my opinion but you want what well my
wife oh I just think they were c-section
your babies are great I'm just saying in
general when they come out of believe a
man may
I met a man made whole they're all
man-made they're beautiful
then if they come out of like the God
made whole yeah my head was real squishy
and pointy when I came out so that's
okay I don't want to get into that
you're you're saying the world would be
a better place if everybody played off
the same playbook of honesty that's
let's let's continue to explore that
there would be repercussions and it
would be it's I'll be like ripping a
huge band-aid off of us that's how
people do it that's that's the secondary
thing but yeah nobody's gonna agree to
this it's only a problem so practically
it'll never happen so I think well it's
it's about threading the needle of the
people you don't have enough enough
enough sense to not ask what do you what
do you think of little Jared if they
don't have you shouldn't you should show
mercy on that person what if they said
you got a thread a needle
what if they specifically yes I said you
know what I'm just been what now first
of all no one's gonna do this but if
they reveal yeah you know what you think
my baby's ugly because I'm trying to
work like well let's go first of all
that's not being public I would
definitely like let's make sure that
it's just the two of us and no one else
can hear this and you're asking me to be
brutally honest but honestly could also
include well first of all Jared it
doesn't matter what jared is ugly or not
because what is beauty Jared I'm sure
Jared will find someone one day or not
find someone if that's not important to
him because yeah what what is beauty but
I think strictly speaking if you want to
know my aesthetic opinion about your kid
I could give it to you of your wants I
think it would be profitable I don't
think it would be profitable yes
probably as a hint as the fact that I
think your baby's hideous right and you
would leave it at that and then they
would say yes I really want to know and
they would say but I think you thread
the needle first if you say I'm not the
best judge of babies you know so it's
like there's an easier way to say if you
press me you're not gonna like the
results they start pageants at very
young ages now Jerry yeah and you can
you go to those recommend your baby
going to make a Craigslist ad I'm sure
no show up it is a great way to start
willing to college
fun though but your kid should probably
look elsewhere yeah maybe not
self-confidence though but I'm not sure
okay you see but you want to be I would
love to be the person that kid thread
the needle you would love to be the
person that lived in a society where
everyone agreed because this is come
come back and bite your brother people
are gonna be honest about you well
here's the thing I think there's a lot
of things to be sacrificed if we move to
a place where truth is actually
important to us
I don't but now first of all I don't
believe that truth is important to many
of us or even really any of us because
we tend to be we tend to think that
we're being very rational when mm
everything we know about the brain at
this point shows us that even the things
that we think are rational decisions are
usually things that are coming for from
the more emotionally driven parts of our
brain and then you know our frontal
cortex the more rational part of the
brain is actually just confirming what
actually happened in the emotional parts
of our brain so even when we think we're
being rational we're actually leading
with our emotions but all that being
said so we're not we're not we're not
chasing truth we're chasing happiness
yeah survival we're chasing the only
things that we can based on the the
millions of years of evolution that
created the brain that we have in the
way that we approach the world and we're
doing the best that we can with it I
agree with that so when a waitress asked
me what do you think and I don't really
like the breadsticks I lie because I'm
chasing the quickest way to get through
a meal that I enjoy which which means no
awkwardness for me and well because o
because well in a simplistic way because
ultimately it benefits your you're
ultimately your experience in your
survival if you have as little conflict
with that waitress especially if you
initiate conflict with that waitress
that's unnecessary and all of a sudden
she turns out to be crazy and she pulls
out a knife and stabs you because she
really cares about the breadsticks
like Olive Garden when you got committed
she could have stabbed me with a
breadstick because they were hard so
what I'm saying is that just socially
everything that has existed for eons has
reinforced you not really valuing
honesty but valuing
getting yourself through a situation so
honesty is kind of as an afterthought
well I believe that now that we actually
have control over all and evolution you
know they work we're conscious beings
and cultural evolution is happening
faster speak for yourself in biological
evolution we actually stand a chance to
implement things like we're going to see
truth differently we're gonna hijack and
commandeer our brain to be used for
different things than it was in the past
and actually value truth more than we
have in the past I think we we have the
ability to do that in the now and into
the future
well that doesn't give your right to not
be kind so there has a needle okay
I think practically that's what we have
to figure out because you're not yeah
you're not president yet yeah sure I
believe in you right okay well the thing
about threading the needle and doing
something - lying to make people feel
better
that is the experience that I will share
I thought I was doing the right thing
sure
I was no I can't eat anything there it
does smell good so mmm it's like coffee
yeah um we also got fried lasagna bites
which laughs how could those not be good
I laughed when I saw that on the menu
what did you order did well yeah it was
I sometimes I laughs I ordered by
laughing okay all right so I was a camp
counselor I may have told you guys this
at some point but I was a camp counselor
at the summer between college and coming
out to LA so I was like 21
I had a cabin full of at the camp that
you like did all your summer camps yeah
that I went to when I was a kid and I
loved and I had a bunch of
twelve-year-old girls in my cabin and we
had a bat that got into the cabin and it
was in the cabin every night for like
three nights we couldn't get rid of it
didn't know what to do and in Maine
because bats carry rabies if you can't
catch the bat and you aren't sure
whether or not it like I don't know
drooled in your eyeball you're supposed
to go get a rabies shot so all these
kids were really scared about getting a
rabies shot and you know the other
counselors were like you just got to get
them
to do it like you know it's optional but
they really should do it
hey so they offered a rabies shot at the
camp no we had to go to the lake
Southern Maine Medical Center so it's I
was like it's a fun-filled trip like
we're gonna get ice cream after it's
gonna be so fun and they were like it
sounds like it's gonna hurt and here's
where I lied
I said no guys I've had a rabies shot
before it's fine it's so fine I was like
I'm gonna go with you I'm gonna get one
myself because I was in there with you
guys and you know what you can watch me
get it so you'll know that it's not a
scary experience and here's where I made
a crucial mistake watch and so a couple
of them came back with me because they
wanted to watch one was smart enough not
to do it and somebody knew you were
alive yeah so I got back there and I'm
like trying to keep my cool and you know
be like I know what I'm doing I've been
this is a you know not my first time at
the rodeo kids but everything they're
saying I'm like getting sweaty or and
sweaty or cuz I it's not at all what I
expected and they're like okay so we're
basing the amount of goo in each shot I
mean I'm sure they didn't say okay so
the amount of rabies goo in each shot is
dependent on your weight and obviously
I'm the heaviest one there so I got the
most goo and they had to split it up
into two shots because I needed to and
then I didn't realize that they do it in
your butt yeah so now we're already in a
bad territory I can't be like you should
get out of here so they stayed in and
I'm like on my hands and knees on the
table in time to stop and the nurses
said okay we're gonna do it on three and
I thought they were gonna do one shot
and these needles are like this big and
she didn't both at the same time in both
of my butt cheeks and I blacked out I
passed out and I woke up to them
screaming because I oh my god I
nosebleed and I woke up like this fine
was fine see kids it was so easy
we had to all do it I'd gone first and I
felt so bad and they were like we
thought you said you done it before and
I had to be like it like burned and hurt
to sit down and then but and I was just
like it's bad just get in there like
just let him do it
Wow so that was a situation where it
turned around and it was um I shouldn't
have lied I should have just been like
don't watch me cuz it's bad if I can -
but it did bite me all right cuz that
one seems like a pretty straightforward
one in retrospect right so yeah there
was no reason for me to live and you
could have said possibly should have
said definitely should have said you
know what I actually have reason to
believe that these shots are very
painful but you know what the effective
rabies will be much more painful
yeah not deadly if we don't get these
shots and so we don't have a choice we
have to do it sometimes you have to do
difficult things kids okay that would
have been a better learning experience
than saying it's great and then just
blacking out in front of them that's not
the best yeah but there are many
situations like that where you can sure
learn from your failure you know maybe
it may be an even better situation would
be like when you're trying to get
somebody to do something that you know
is not going to harm them or whatever
and you like make up some statistic
about you know well I mean this is
actually true but you know like you I
know your wife is like she gets she
doesn't do it very much anymore but she
doesn't like flying in that you got the
statistic well you're actually much more
likely to die on the way to the airport
in the car than you are in the in the
plane well that's actually true that's a
good statistic right but conceivably
there would be a situation where you
knew that she was gonna be fine but you
said something to her to get her to calm
down while she while you were trying to
fly right I mean that if I were a better
person yes I would do that but I
continued to kind of snicker and OH
blink or just sleep that was how you
dealt with it yeah but I was a point out
that Lizzie was she was lying in order
to save their lives
but it would have been better if I just
told the truth well
no because I think what what you I guess
what you were feeling was at stake was
that they may refuse the shot or and
then their lives are in your hands
a kid gets rabies because of you well
cuz of a bat well because of you okay
cuz you couldn't get rid of the bat I
couldn't I tried to catch it for three
nights in a row any other container and
an oven mitt gets the bat kind of this
was a poke a well she was trying to
protect them by lying so if that was the
case I think your error is not that the
error was letting them watch ya the
error was not only in my line but I've
also said to you I want to prove to you
I'm not lying right and and and you
can't sometimes you can't prove that
yeah because you're lying
well and to your point about like making
up a statistic there's actually somebody
who made a comment about this this is
interesting so Tiffany Mendoza said my
parentheses at the time five-year-old
daughter didn't want to hold my hand
crossing the street she's run out in
front of a car before by wriggling out
of my grip while my other hand was
carrying groceries and I nearly had a
heart attack so I told her that the
greasy spots in the parking lot were
from kids that didn't hold mommy or
daddy's hand and they got squished
needless to say she's now much more
careful in parking lots and near roads
so how does that feature into your it's
an interesting thing like the why is
that that's like a wives tale lie you
know that is it right no it's like it's
not true there's 30 spots or not
children yeah it could be I actually
don't know what they are no we've
determined that they're gone yeah and
other sticky stuff and just oil slick
hard yes but it turns out that old wives
have a knack for weaving tails that are
the great thing about them is that
they're memorable they stick with you
you know whereas if you would have if
the mom would have told the truth
that's just like well you could get hit
by a car if there's something about it
doesn't resonate with a child or it
doesn't so I understand like the the
well-meaning approach to to such a
ridiculous lie
understand it but is it isn't this what
we're doing okay yeah
if you the thing is is that we're not
choosing between two options if the
options were if you do not tell this lie
your daughter is at risk okay so
obviously if you just distill it down to
those two options then you're justified
and because from a moral standpoint you
know protecting your daughter from
becoming a greasy spot on the road is
more important there's more it's a
higher moral calling than not telling
her a fairy tale right but those aren't
the two it's not it's actually it
there's more options than that right
there's a higher option which is I can
tell her the truth about what will
happen to her if it may not be as fun
and it may not be as immediately
compelling but as I think about my
relationship with my daughter is I think
about you know what my word means to her
listen I'm nothing against Tiffany I do
I do I tell my kids stories all the time
it's one of my hobbies is just make
stuff up that had not even to teach him
a lesson just because it entertained to
me so I'm not speaking from a moral high
ground here but I'm saying that you
screw with the kids all the time
theoretically I'm saying that as the
society as a species if we could call
ourselves to a higher standard where we
were like you know what I'm going to
tell my kid the truth about this
situation because I feel like ultimately
they will benefit more if they just
understand the truth of this situation
and act on it as opposed to having to be
told a story in order to be compelled
listen here a kindergarten child of mine
if you don't hold my hand while crossing
the street
you're gonna get hit by a car it's not
gonna kill you instantaneously it'll
it'll probably hurt a whole lot there'll
be some internal bleeding I mean a
little bit of blood will be coming out
of your nose maybe your ears maybe even
your eyes but it's all the blood inside
of you in places that it shouldn't be
that's ultimately gonna kill you very
slowly while I'm calling 911 to get you
to the hospital to be fair this would
work I think and I agree with your work
though it's not fun but it's not me down
the road though because the issue with
telling these these types of stories to
and I I don't think my parents did a lot
of this to me it's probably why I'm very
anxious they told me the truth a lot but
it if you do tell a kid something like
the greasy spot story at some point
they're gonna find out that it's not
true and when they do find that out then
all of a sudden you're the value of your
word goes down a little bit and also
then they're maybe not when they know
it's not true they're like well I'm not
gonna get hit by a car I'm not gonna
look when I'm jaywalking you know
whatever but I don't know I'm
contradicting myself now because the
more I think about it stories are so
compelling right I mean that's that's
how we as that's how humans have like
defined who we are we make up stories
about how we got here and every culture
has the story of how we got here and why
we're here and you know you know they
don't line up with the science but
they're compelling and they actually
bring us together as cultures and I
don't know there's a there's a reason
that we're that were compelled by these
stories whether or not they're they're
not they're true or not so I don't know
maybe maybe I've got some unrealistic
thing where I'm like calling people to
some sort of robotic state which is like
you said a lot less fun the story the
Grimm's fairy tales are very fun and we
as we talked about on the show before I
think you did the research for that
episode they were all intended to teach
kids lessons and they were actually much
more Grimm
yeah they're originally then then the
updated versions but I don't know I
doesn't as the result or the fun had in
the process justify the dishonesty I
think you know what it's it's not a
rational thing to make the greasy spot
story up but there are plenty of people
who do it not like you for the fun of it
so I mean we're we're making light of it
saying it's for fun I don't I don't
think they do it for fun I think they do
it because you innately know that story
is effective more effective what I
already said but I don't I so but it's
not a thread that needle well is it
technically a lie is the other question
because technically quote-unquote a lie
has to be an intentionally false
statement or you know you're you have to
be trying to deceive someone in order
for it to be a lie so misinformation is
not
nucleoli so if if I guess my question
there would be is the facts are we
talking about alternative facts oh sure
misinformation I guess if well if you
are intending to deceive if you know
what you are saying is untrue and you
are actively intending to deceive with
misinformation than that is a lie but if
you're not if you're just disseminating
misinformation that's not a lie even if
it's incorrect
even if what's coming out of your mouth
is wrong it's technically not a lie your
motivations matter yeah you're lying is
entirely about motivation so if the
motivation is not so much to deceive
your child as it is to stop them from
running into the road is that a lie you
will it you might not be a greasy spot
on the road you you could get hit by a
car and died so a lot I mean if it if it
my definition of a lies if it doesn't
match up with truth whether you know it
or not the Oxford English Dictionary
disagrees with you well I've been I've
been screening their call yeah I do
think III do think you're at your intent
but but I would say that this but in the
case of the mother and that's a lie it
wasn't the intention was to deceive yeah
the intention was to deceive in order to
interpret X right but still the
intention is there that's true well I
guess I do agree with that not what I
just said before that are you lying no
give us another lie story all right
oh I like this one Josh summer Levinson
said I sometimes tell my husband that I
have to poop and that he has to watch
the kids
but I usually just I thought I said I
sometimes tell my husband I have to poop
and he has to watch that's just weird
watch me drop the kids off in the you
know what is this commenter for some
people enjoy there will be a public
comment if they want to do it in the
privacy of their own home sometimes to
start over because I was in the wrong
alright so I this I sometimes tell my
husband that I have to poop and that he
has to watch the kids
usually just say kit Oreos okay so I'm
sorry that he has to watch the kids but
I usually just sneak in Oreos and eat
them in the bathroom closet if I told
him the truth he would want my Oreo
sometimes all I need is peace and Oreos
so I don't lose it I feel no shame I
support that it just wants to eat his
Oreos in peace I mean it listen this is
tough because he he the dad yeah
this is tough because obviously I don't
I mean I I am one of these people I'm
the person who tells the kid the story
I'm the person who tells my wife I'm
going to poop so I can eat Oreos in the
closet is my other question no he's in
the closet in the bathroom it's like he
goes one step further it's a bathroom
inception he's he's inside speaking of
shame I mean you go I mean you're going
into the bathroom and then into a room
inside of the bed what are you trying to
hide where is but again so I'm not
saying that I do this but I just have to
believe that ultimately the relationship
would be enhanced if there if this kind
of thing didn't exist
that's deception for nothing but
selfishness I mean this is pretty
clear-cut the Oreos in the closet not
serious well it's not on the same level
who is reading Oreo was another person
who is eating them in the closet that's
a problem right yeah that would be a
problem that's not what is happening
these are cookies and cookie can also be
someone's name but that's not what we're
talking about people the morals oh I'm
so I don't fault this person I'm just
saying that I'm trot I just believe that
if we just turn one more corner and
we're like you know what that's serious
we don't do that we don't tell those
kinds of lies even though it's about
Oreos in the bathroom what we don't do
it because we value honesty in a new and
different way I don't I I don't think
I've ever gone into the bathroom to
imply that I was pooping and I never
attempted to poop
but I do stay in there a lot longer than
I need you to right so I mean that is
deception I'm deceiving my family and
they know it like they'll come knock on
the door you're like get out of there
you're on your phone we're not making me
watch it not even much of a deception I
mean there's there's a few places you
can go that you can have any like Oreo
time you know what I'm saying
right or phone time or just like just
nuttin not having to answer to someone
else's needs sure it's selfishness
you know but maybe there's no hope yeah
you know I just maybe this is just maybe
this is just all too ingrained you know
it's just too ingrained but if you say
but why can't you just come out and say
you know what when dad's pooping we all
know that I'm not actually pooping that
I'm on my phone or I just need some
quiet time this is my safe place that I
want I just want you to give me some
space so I'm not deceiving you I'm only
gonna go in here if I need to poop or be
I need to have some a long time oh and
and I just want to be real about that
and then there you go it's it's it
everybody's on the same page well you
know the advantage to that is that now
the family understands the dad needs his
oreo time right and you could have it
somewhere other than the bathroom maybe
want it maybe they maybe they need to
understand that you have needs it could
be a garage or a shed but what about the
what about the classier classic example
a bedroom somebody gets you and just
somebody may have submitted the
questions anybody submit a question
about getting a present from someone
yeah we got a bunch okay so that's the
classic example that I've been thinking
about this scenario let's hear it then
well now I'm trying to find one of them
oh here we go
Megan Hester when my son really wanted
the commemorative gmm coin I told him I
missed the ordering deadline and wasn't
able to get it for him gave it to him
for Christmas so she got him a gift and
lied and said that she couldn't get it
and then she gave it to him tomorrow
night off look even better
this isn't well well
to make a bigger surprise this isn't a
surprise party category right yeah it is
I've planned something for you and you
say where we going oh we're going here
but you're really going to a surprise
party
are we really like I'm not really
willing to give up surprise parties I
don't even like surprise parties oh
they're stressful but as a culture do I
think that not lying for surprise
parties is something that needs to go
away I don't think so no that's a fun
like then you're like no you got me it's
but you know well specifically with
presents what I'm talking about is
grandma gets you a sweater oh and you've
already got the sweater that situation I
think you have to say you love it you
don't have a choice but no but what if
you but no but in the in the in the new
world that I'm trying to usher but I'm
not really sure if I want to utter it in
you tell grandma grandma I really
appreciate this gift you know what I
actually have this sweater already we
have a couple options you know what I
can have a backup sweater you got me a
backup sweater or I really appreciate
this but I already have it and I'm
totally fine with keeping it you can do
whatever you want to I pre I appreciate
the gift I appreciate the gesture but
but I'm letting you know I already have
why do you let them know though couldn't
you just say I really appreciate the
gift
I love the silence parenthetically
that's why I already have one right you
don't need to finish that sentence so I
I like the way you're you're going with
this you're trying to maintain the truth
but do it in a way that is doesn't hurt
anybody's feelings you're trying to get
the best of both worlds which majorie
that maybe the all part of law the
ultimate ethic there isn't you know
thread the needle I I think the
interesting thing is do you already have
this one you say yes do you already have
this one and do you like it yes and yes
again if someone's asking pointed
questions I think you can either say do
you really want to know and then if they
press then you could give me the answer
okay yeah at a certain point you every
needle can't be threaded some needles
have no holes that feels like a threat
like the do you really want to know but
that's good that's
better because they'll be like oh I
guess not you know and I kind of already
know it they already know the answer
when you say like that
yeah that's what I mean it's a little
scary I think the interesting thing is
lying in in order for the betterment of
somebody else which is like for a
surprise party or something like that
but then there's certain times when you
lie to protect them or to make their
lives better but you never know what it
does that is the truth always better
like here's another example my mom calls
me on the phone she lives on an opposite
coast from me she can't tell how well
I'm doing so she asks how are you doing
and maybe I'm not doing well that moment
that day or that month who knows I'm
always very inclined to say I'm fine
because I don't feel like I feel like
she's pretty hamstrung to help me that I
wouldn't want to burden her with
something that she's powerless to help
with so I would I lie and tell her I'm
okay now this is mostly hypothetical I'm
not thinking of a specific issues about
doing okay I am doing okay thank you for
asking and if you're right here in my
presence and but my instinct might be if
somebody's like how are you be like good
you know in general you say that in a
small talk setting man I had one friend
who was like who would always be honest
and then the response most of the time
would be like you know would never say
this but then they'd be like what was
that guy was actually honest now I've
got it well and then they caught me
exactly how he was and now I got happens
the conversation becomes about very
focused on the person who said they
weren't good right you're up you're
burdening somebody else which is maybe
okay but but if it's like your mom is
sometimes I might say like I'm okay just
because I wouldn't want to burden my mom
that seems like a good impulse but you
never know what good can come from the
truth it's like there's so much risk
when you're justifying a lie mm-hmm I
think there's a lot more risk
that's baggage to allies and there is
risk of the truth now the risk of
awkwardness or hurting someone's
feelings in the short term again you got
to thread the needle and be as kind as
you can but in this but it's a risk and
being truthful is much lower than being
than lying even for their own good how
about this so what if we agreed you're
not gonna get the whole human race to do
this but like what if there was a small
community of people who are like we
agree to be perfectly honest with each
other right and your mom and you were in
that community now when your mom asks
you how you're doing if she is part of
that agreement she now knows that that
is not an empty question she knows that
question has an answer and that question
may have an answer that is I'm not doing
too well and now we're talking about how
I'm doing he'll already knew that my mom
my mom my already knew that my mom that
wouldn't be an empty question for my mom
no that's not that's not what I mean as
opposed to small talk but that's not
what I mean I'm not saying it was just
small talk what I'm saying is that if
you move to this higher ethic right or
the more honest ethic whatever it is and
the people in the community agreed to
that the people's questions would be
more calculated and more measured
because it's like I'm not gonna just how
you doing is no longer a greeting
because I only say it when I mean it and
I because right now we're in this
in-between stage where we value honesty
but we don't really value honesty we
have all these cultural convention
conventions like saying how you do and
when you meet somebody and the answer is
supposed to be all right good fine
yeah yeah you're switching the onus from
like in terms of a question from the
from the right now the onus is on the
person who receives the question to
discern did they really do they really
want to know the answer to that question
or what do they want to hear and then
it's the it's the question of are you
gonna give them what they want to hear
does that person really don't want to
know how I'm doing or are they just
being friendly and think about all this
think about all the things that might
change and who knows may I don't know
I'm not a historian
maybe there's a culture that in some way
people have valued honesty differently
in the past maybe there's some some
people group that like work valued this
more and I
I would love to see like how gift-giving
and all these other things we're in
greetings were impacted by somebody who
really values honesty to like an almost
obsessive level like that would be an
interesting social experiment it's
obviously there's been movies about it
liar liar oh yeah but like if everybody
agreed to be that honest like what what
happened what happened in liar liar well
he learned about himself he learned that
he lied too much and that there was a
happy medium to strike in terms of lying
and he got his family back because he
was brutally honest right am I making
that up if so I'm gonna write a new
movie that's nothing so long he was like
hit in the head and then he could only
tell the truth no it's like a magic
thing I think it can only tell me some
lawyer right big fancy lawyer and then
he can only tell the truth and he can't
like lie to his kid anymore about why he
can't pick the kid up yes to let you
know and it's Jim Carrey he's like
fighting with himself in the bathroom
mirror I think yeah I think that's right
yeah yeah I mean it happens like when
he's on a case and he's yes and he's
like a defense attorney he has only had
to be honest though about his guilty it
was a great way to illustrate it but I'm
just here's one I'm advocate I'm not
advocating something unrealistic like
you are what I'm advocating is when ever
pot we pursue conveying truth whenever
possible in the kindest way possible and
it's very difficult to do but so like
when my mom asked me if something if I'm
bothered by something and my mom asked
me and I think it's like I'm not okay
it's like I and I don't want her to
worry
well you know what maybe I learned
something about my mom when I tell her
that something's bothering me and then
we have a conversation that otherwise we
wouldn't have had or she has input or
you know it's like a lot a lot of times
it happens not when it's like how are
you doing but like with medical
conditions sometimes you'll wait to tell
somebody that you've undergone a test
until you know the results
because you know that hey you have
certain family members that will worry
endlessly about you is that a lot dad
just did that waiting to say that you're
pregnant yeah and how did you feel about
that when because I wish he told me
because he he told me after the fact
that he'd had I think they saw something
in like a scan in his lung or something
and he didn't tell me it like any of
that at all until several weeks later
when it came back and he was fine
because he didn't want you to worry in
the rectum he didn't want to burden you
with it yeah but it was a truly so it
seems like a truly selfless motivation
no it was it was I know it's cuz he
didn't want to stress me out or anything
but I do wish I had known about that why
uh I don't know I want you know I would
want him to feel like he can tell me
that stuff and not not feel like it's a
burden to me because it wouldn't have
been right because you love him and you
can't maybe you wouldn't say
specifically what you would do but the
general premise is that when you love
somebody it's like him telling you may
have been a way for him to experience
the love of his daughter right and it's
like you can't quantify that and you
can't predict you can't predict what
what can again it's the risk of of
keeping the truth from somebody versus
telling the truth it's like well is it
gonna make him worry well what are you
risking losing like a certain type of
connection with your daughter
yeah conversation and yeah so it's I
think that's the difficult thing is we
there's we have these instincts to live
for good reasons but it may be
short-sighted so I think I think that's
a good example of a time where we should
just say okay it's almost like a faith
in truth overriding the fate then what
what you think is gonna happen well you
really think that the the ultimately the
best will come out of out of out of
honesty but but you can be brutally
honest you can be a total jerk you can
you but not at the expense of people I
have a friend who I actually think walks
the line that you guys
our our thinking is the good line to
walk threads the needle yeah I think he
does he's he's extremely honest and but
it's it's not honest to a fault like I I
think that he withhold certain
information when he feels like he needs
to but he's somebody that I don't think
I've ever had a conversation with that
wasn't completely earnest like if if he
asked me how I was and I were to say not
good he fully would be invested in that
conversation and also if I were to ask
him how he's doing and he's not doing
well there's no way he would say I'm
great he would say so if you with him
because you know him he's kind of and
you know he's playing - like retz coat
you actually wouldn't ask him how he was
doing because you're playing with fire
because you might be in a 20 minute
conversation no it's never it that's the
crazy thing is it's never a 20 minute
conversation it's it's always it never
feels it never feels like a burden which
like that's what the line I think you're
trying to walk is that you don't want to
you don't want to put unnecessary stress
and other people by being honest but I'm
not sure it does stress them out because
this person is extremely honest and it
means that you can trust every
conversation with them you know are
their ethic are their like competing
ethical worldviews yeah about this in
terms of I bet there's a hard line there
is so I mean there's there's basically
two camps of theories about lying in
general and one is the the camp from
let's start with German philosopher
Immanuel Kant boy I hope their German
read that somewhere and wrote it down
but I've been wrong before so and the
theory behind this is that lying is
always wrong no matter what doesn't
matter and this is actually where the
scenario of the there's a murderer at
your door comes from because the
argument here is that there's a murderer
at your door they're asking is right
under the couch red is under the couch
you are still supposed to say yes rats
under the couch please come into my
house he yeah absolutely
everything that I've read from him
though like he's the way the way I
believe so yeah but just like cotton
ethics you know like the way that he
approaches things it's like there's a
there's little sacrifices made along the
way
but it's like it's very I don't know
it's because the way my brain works but
it's like it's very attractive way of
but what's the thinking so what what's
the what how can you make that
attractive then what's the justification
ultimately it will bring about good yeah
good yeah I mean maybe not even so he
has them just pretty pristine faith in
truth it's a long view no I didn't even
remember that he was the one that talked
about this but he's one of many and does
he talk about okay so then the murderer
comes in or and kills the person and
then what you get out of there because
they're probably gonna kill you you're a
witness that's no way he's no I didn't
read that far I you know I got to the
the point where that he has a hard line
on lying as do other people you know
another another fun party girl I'm Rand
once said there are no white lies
there's only the blackest of destruction
and a white lie is the blackest of all
seems fun a good time but you know on
the other hand there's a lot of people
that argue that lying is essential to
human existence and that it's a natural
part of life it's something we're never
gonna stop doing because it's just what
we're built to do well I agree with that
I don't have a justifies it well there's
there's the other side of the coin is
that you know if you are protecting
yourself or the life of someone else of
course it is okay and it is your duty to
do it and if you don't do it then you're
not protecting someone a really great
philosopher once said I always tell the
truth even when I lie and that
philosopher is Al Pacino so he always
can always learn something from him even
winning like he did I mean were any of
those scenarios presented by the
mythical beast that okay I lied and I'm
proud of it yes
so this is something that I or I'm happy
I did or it was the right thing well so
I went through a lot of a lot of the
beasts comments which was very
interesting and one thing that kept
coming up more times than I expected to
see was something like this next comment
that I'm going to read to you so this is
something that appeared upwards of 10
times that
East okay this person I'm gonna keep
anonymous but she said on a more serious
note I lied to my abuser after a fight
that quote I love you and were good so I
could go to work instead I went to the
police station
survival makes you do crazy things
sometimes so that's a situation in which
there is I don't see any way that you
could argue to this person that that was
not the right thing to do
there I can't do it yeah you can't
Emanuel yeah I mean yeah and I mean
survival makes you do crazy things it
also makes you do same things that seems
very sane yeah but this was not the only
one I mean there were so many people who
were saying like I lied I said I was
going to work and really I took my kids
and I went to a shelter I there were a
bunch of yes and I think this is this is
where you get into the the rub which is
it's it's fun and easy to sit around and
have philosophical conversations about
how the truth is always the ultimate
good and it supersedes any particular
situation but it is the particular
situations especially when you attach a
name to them in a specific story and a
specific experience and I think that
that for me is the reason that I don't
think that you can do what cotton said I
don't I don't think you can ever get
there because we're experiencing these
ethics in the context of people and who
we are right so when it begins to feel
unnatural and it begins to feel it
begins to feel wrong right for me to
tell someone and I don't have this is
not my experience I haven't experienced
anything like that personally I can only
imagine how horrible it would be but for
me to then say no I have an ethic that
supersedes your situation and you
actually should not have lied to your
abuser in that situation the reason it
feels wrong it's probably because it is
wrong right and so I can't miss it so I
the line is wrong the reason if it would
feel wrong to set to tell her that she
should she she should have lied
yeah
absolutely and so I think that that's
how that's how you that's how you find
the thread for the needle right is it's
like we can have these high standards
but once it begins to not make sense in
specific situations easily when it in
date eminently yeah angels you or
someone else then it's there are more
important things at stake than being
truthful in a moment absolutely and
there's also something that I came
across I was watching some old louis c.k
stand up and something that he said it's
a joke obviously but he said lying is
amazingly useful in life how do you tell
a kid not to use a thing that just
solves every possible problem which
obviously that's a joke you don't want a
kid to lie about everything however like
there are situations in which it's
useful that that woman's story being one
of them like she had to do that to be
able to get out and to be able to get to
the police station so you know I'm glad
that you went to the more serious place
but let's wrap up with a more jovial lie
sure you got one more for us - yeah
knock it out of the happy part yeah I
got my favorite one here for you I guess
I'll leave this one anonymous as well
someone said I sharted once and told
everyone I was walking funny cuz I had
fallen while skateboarding I don't know
what the lie they told was about the
smell or you know how do you do coming
out of there sure you do a short walk
and make it look like you injured
yourself on a skateboard like if you're
trying to make it look like your knees
bad fell on my hips
yeah I sharted once and really told my
it was in the car with my family on the
way to Dollywood and we just turned
right around
you just don't good lie I didn't lie
actually how can you lie like everyone's
gonna know that's not my car I sharted
and then I just pulled over and turned
around there like why just head to
mintern and I was like kids I poked my
britches i sharted it hasn't happened to
me yet that I've poked my pants as an
adult and I keep being told that it will
happen
never happened to me is it over 30 is it
don't trust a fart over 30 and that's
what I gotta know so if it was an age
thing I don't know I think it was I was
not doing well okay but don't make it an
age thing I didn't lie I don't know I
have the sphincter of a of an adolescent
it's very tight what does that mean I
don't know
that's a horrific thing to say don't
ever say what she's making like we're
old that's why you're sorry but I have a
sharp I've literally heard don't trust a
fart after 30 like people don't told me
that I'm now afraid I have two more
years there's no doubt that that it's
it's in your future no but where do we
land we're never farted more than 29
times in a row maybe that's what it
means
where did where did I had counted oh
I've counted my where I've landed at the
end of this conversation is that I think
in a situation you know what I'll go
back to what you just said where if it
feels if you feel wrong about something
or you feel like you're doing harm to
someone else by lying don't do it but if
if it feels fine if you're doing it to
protect yourself if it's a situation
where you have to do it which obviously
does exist it's I think it's a necessary
part of the human existence well I
completely agree with that I think the
thing I was hoping would happen is it
the end of this conversation we would be
the first three to sign a global
contract of just know that was in like I
was in my imagination but like
practically what I was hoping is that
the next time I'm at a restaurant and
the waitress asked me how is it I'll be
honest because she's asking the question
because she wants another answer I think
you should in that scenario and but I
but I don't I just felt that I don't
feel motivated right now to do that I
kind of feel like I'm just gonna be like
it's good I think from what I want to do
better that's related to where I've
landed in this conversation which is I'm
gonna try to be more cognizant of when
am prevaricated what I'm just gonna
saving that word
I'm hold I just remembered it I don't
know what that word I think it means a
lot o prevaricate why you so many
letters we need to say Li e I want to be
more aware of when I'm lying or not
being truthful in everyday situations
and trying to thread the needle and take
the high road of truth and seeing what
happens but doing it with as as kind as
possible
a issuing a personal challenge to say
okay I'm gonna say you know what these
breadsticks are hard as a rock
but my hopes were so high because I
remember them being so great and I
believe that there's some back there
that are wink wink you know what maybe
it's maybe it comes down to being always
honest to yourself regardless of what
you're saying and if you honestly know
that what you're saying doesn't need to
be alive sounds like some a serial
killer would say that's fair I've heard
that before
that way I like I like where you're
where you're landing on this me or
Lizzie cuz I think I think that I I
think that they're related and I I think
she is she was complimenting what you
were saying he wasn't contradicting what
you're saying what what I hear you
saying is that maybe the reason that
were frightened of being honest is
because we're frightened of the way we
would be we'd the way we would be honest
mm-hmm so if we can learn to be honest
in tactful ways then we might find that
honesty is actually a lot easier than we
ever imagined that it's the best policy
honesty is the best policy that is what
we've arrived at but I didn't but I I
didn't mean to short-circuit your your
statement with the serial killer thing
and if I did please finish it no it's
gone
I already have the handwriting of
Charles Manson so I'm like one step
behind that already so but if you feel
that way I think these are complementary
perspectives guys yeah yeah if you feel
a certain way about the breadsticks and
that is what you feel that's honestly
what you feel be honest with yourself
but when someone asks you how you how
the breadsticks are be honest with them
but don't be an a-hole yeah that's all
it is just be honest being honest whole
being honest whole bnh whole V&H whole
yes yes there we go an H whole that's
the ethic that we have arrived at be an
H whole I'm happy with that
put that on a t-shirt it won't make
sense to anyone
[Music]